ce sondage publié hier qui a forcément
interpellé les locataires de l'elysée et
de matignon plus d'un français sur deux
estiment que leur pouvoir d'achat a
plutôt diminué pendant le quinquennat
est ce justifié premier élément de
réponse tout de suite reportage signé
cécile 6e hausse des salaires de 10%
baisse des charges salariales
augmentation du smic de gauche à droite
les candidats à l'elysée ont tous leurs
idées sur les moyens d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat mais qu'en est-il
vraiment les français ont-ils vraiment
moins d'argent dans leur portefeuille
pour la sénatrice et l'air sophie primas
si ce n'est pas encore le cas il y a des
raisons de s'inquiéter car toutes les
dépenses courantes sont dans le rouge le
coût de l'énergie qu'on nous annonce est
en galopant j'ai une petite inquiétude
sur l'inflation sur les produits
alimentaires
nous avons également pris du logement on
voit bien que des décisions par exemple
comme l'annoncent généralisée de
l'encadrement des loyers et bien elle
fait que les investisseurs ont des
rentabilités sur le logement qui vont
baisser le sénateur socialiste david
assouline estime lui que les retraités
ont effectivement perdu du pouvoir
d'achat et qu'il existe chez le reste
des français un sentiment très fort de
déclassement social là les parents
souvent pensent que leurs enfants
pourront pas faire aussi bien qu'eux et
eux-mêmes ont le sentiment de descendre
au long de leur vie au lieu de monter
socialement et ça se taisent
particulièrement par le pouvoir d'achat
pour pascal s'ils veulent des lits
sénateur communiste du val de marne il y
a urgence avec 10 millions de français
qui vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté il estime qu'il ne faut pas
attendre les présidentielles pour mettre
le sujet sur la table il faut il faut tu
es maintenant à voir et notamment pour
ce qui concerne le parlement une loi de
finances à la hauteur et des décisions
qui sont prises
les pouvoirs publics ont du pouvoir sur
la question de l'augmentation ou pas de
l'eau de l'électricité du gaz à payer
par exemple aujourd'hui six français sur
dix estiment que leur pouvoir d'achat a
baissé avec emmanuel macron
notre pouvoir d'achat at-il vraiment
baissé on en débat tout de suite avec
monique lubin bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste des landes vice
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales fabrice le sachet
bonjourbonjour mieux aussi un
entrepreneur vice président et porte
parole du medef j'accueille également
eric delannoy bienvenue à vous
économiste et président de tenzing
conseil en visioconférence avec nous
frédérick michaud qui est directeur
général adjoint d'opinionway bonsoir
c'est ce et opinionway qui a réalisé ce
sondage pour nos confrères de radio
classique et les échos et j'accueille
évidemment laetitia cru pas notre
éditorialiste bonsoir l'était hier soir
là ils s'organisent des mardis et jeudis
mathieu c'est mathieu poissant l'otc
lundi et mercredi je vais je vais
démarrer j'ai bien faire ça dans les
débats de sens public par la question
générale notre pouvoir d'achat at-il
vraiment baissé eric delannoy alors les
chiffres disent que non puisque canter
se sont pas les chais du gouvernement ce
sont les chiffres de l'insee qui montre
que depuis 2010 est le pouvoir d'achat
des français a augmenté chaque année on
est entre 0 6 % en 2020 1 7% en 2010 9,1
2017 et le plus haut et en 2019 où il y
avait eu les accompagnements suite au
logis les jeunes hommes avaient augmenté
pouvoir d'achat de 2,1 pour cent donc
les chiffres de l'insee montre que le
pouvoir d'achat n'a jamais autant
augmenté d'ailleurs ça n'a jamais autant
augmenté depuis 20 ans en fait quand on
regarde les chiffres le seul problème
c'est que il ya la perception et la
réalité la réalité c'est que ça n'a
baissé que ça et c'est que le pouvoir
d'achat augmenter la perception c'est
que non pour plein de raisons très
disparaître la première des raisons je
pense simplement parce que cette
augmentation de pouvoir d'achat n'est
pas homogène c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
elle elle bénéficie aux classes moyennes
pas aux classes inférieures pas aux
classes inférieures au sens pauvreté du
terme pas aux gens qui se sentent des
classes et un seul chiffre quand on voit
les enseignants par exemple 1 en 1981 un
salaire d'un enseignant débutant
représenté 2 3% du smic aujourd'hui le
salaire d'un enseignant débutant e
représente 1,6 fois le smic on voit bien
qu'ils aient un déclassement dans le
temps sur cette catégorie qui ne peut ne
pas estimer et puis à d'autres raisons
sur écran but et on va évidemment il
revenir le principe de sens public je
voulais déjà dit je le répète c'est
qu'on a du temps c'est un luxe
aujourd'hui dans le paysage médiatique
maison que vous aurez les uns les autres
du temps frédéric micheau je me tourne
vers vous puisque voilà vous êtes à
l'origine de de ce sondage moi j'ai
envie d'un employé une expression de
météo quoi quand on parle des
températures il ya les températures
réelles et les températures ressenties
est ce que vous diriez un petit peu la
même chose pour ce sondage
oui absolument mais c'est vrai tous les
sondages il ya ce qui vient d'être
intervenant au plateau c'est à dire la
différence entre la perception et la
réalité dans notre métier nous savons
pertinemment qu'il peut y avoir des
décalages qui sont d'ailleurs souvent
très significatif 1 comme c'est le cas
ici et puis aussi la limite de tout
sondage qui est à la fois l'ennemi du
déclaratif on ne nous dit que ce que on
veut le dire et puis il faut toujours
contextualiser un sondage et la même
somme dans un contexte très particulier
un contexte de précampagne électorale
on commence à voir les préférences
idéologiques
s'exacerber ses visées on voit bien dans
l'étude des tval selon la sympathie
partisane pour le dire rapidement égale
seulement les sympathisants des maliens
makoun qui constate une amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat et puis le plus
généralement mon sang tan dung nous
sommes encore dans un contexte qui était
très morose évidemment au plan sanitaire
n'est possible au plan économique tout
ça ce sont différentes dimensions qu'il
faut tenir compte dans l'analyse des
résultats de cette étude avec le
évidemment fait ni chaud je reviendrai
vers vous régulièrement pendant ce ce
débat monique lubin est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec avec eric delannoy quand
il dit
voilà les chiffres sont là le pouvoir
d'achat des français a augmenté depuis
le début du quinquennat et peut-être
jamais autant que depuis vingt ans je
lui fait confiance c'est à dire que les
données qu'il a fournies ils sont elles
sont scientifiques donc je ne vais pas
les contester par contre la proche des
plus modestes de ce pays n'est
certainement pas celle là parce que
quand monsieur l'a expliqué les classes
les plus populaires les plus pauvres
d'entre nous n'ont pas ressenti cette
augmentation est la crise a mis en avant
un certain nombre de métiers de
personnes qui exercent et des métiers
la crise les a mis au grand jour tout le
monde sait maintenant les deux
s'occupent celles et ceux qui étaient en
première ligne c'est ça tout le monde
sait maintenant que ce sont des métiers
qui sont extrêmement mal payé et je
pense que ces situations là sont bien
maintenant présente à l'esprit des
français
et il me semble que c'est pour un
certain pour ces raisons là que les
français en règle générale considère que
le pouvoir d'achat n'ont pas augmenté
parce que les professions les plus
pauvres et les professions les plus
impliqués j'ai envie de dire celles qui
sont sur le terrain au quotidien dont on
a besoin tous les jours et dont on parle
très peu sont eux des gens mal payés
alors on va parler évidemment ce sera un
des sous thèmes de ce débat de la
question de l'augmentation des salaires
mais fabrice le sache et peut-être sur 7
sur ce que vient de dire
monique lubin mois effectivement les
premières lignes on sait tous que les
petits bandits va falloir faire quelque
chose et puis là pour l'instant il se
passe pas grand chose pour ceux qui
étaient en première ligne non mais
peut-être revenir sur le pouvoir d'achat
ya quand même une problématique
structurelle de dépenses pré-engagées on
voit que pour les personnes les plus
précaires ces dépenses pré-engagées
aubert le pouvoir d'achat les factures
d'électricité les factures de téléphonie
mobile le prix les mots l'immobilier les
dépenses pour lesquelles vous n'avez pas
d'arbitrage possible parce qu'en début
de mois ou en fin de mois vous êtes sûr
de devoir les payer et donc on voit que
la partie disponible en capacité d'être
arbitré pour des loisirs diminue et ça
ça pose un problème pour une partie de
la population sur la question du
logement c'est vraiment un problème
structurel notamment dans les métropoles
quand on pense que 30 à 40% de certains
salaires parts dans le coût du logement
c'est un vrai problème on a des
solutions un choc de construction c'est
d'autant plus frustrant que il ya
l'investissement privé pour construire
dans ce pipe on n'a pas les permis de
construire donc il ya des leviers
d'action des matériaux aussi en ce
moment mais bon ça c'est quand même un
problème qui perdure depuis des années
conjoncturel prenne un peu de temps des
problématique conjoncturelle le prix des
matières premières la tonne d'acier
était à 250 300 dollars il ya un an un
an plus tard elle est à 1500 $ donc tout
ce qui est fait à base d'acier se vend
plus cher donc il ya des tensions
inflationnistes qui sont liées à cette
tension du cours des matières premières
qu'on retrouve et qui obère le boire la
chasse et on a moins de pouvoir d'achat
si les prix vous avez mois répondu à ma
question les premières lignes vie
répondant à barisis alors les premières
lignes c'est la question du salaire
alors déjà on n'a pas la main sur tous
les salaires c'est pas les entreprises
privées il ya des agents publics donc
une responsabilité de l'état il se
trouve que l'état était moins généreux
que les entreprises privées dans les
dernières années dans le secteur privé
les salaires ont augmenté plus vite que
l'inflation si on prend 2019 s'est à peu
près en moyenne quasiment 2%
d'augmentation des salaires en moyenne
l'inflation est en dessous de 2% donc on
a fait le travail d'augmentation des
salaires ensuite sur les salaires on
peut pas avoir un raisonnement nationale
depuis paris vous avez des entreprises
qui sont soumises à la concurrence
internationale d'autres pas là des
entreprises pour lesquelles ça se passe
bien de pas un hôtel même dans un même
secteur un hôtel de trois étoiles à
paris avec un taux d'occupation de 20 à
30% aujourd'hui il peut pas augmenter
sert un hôtel qui est sur le littoral
qui a fait une super saison peut-être
que lui il peut augmenter les salaires
et toute ascension aux mesures
nationales aux mesures générales je suis
bien évidemment la parole tout à l'heure
les ti s'est cru pas je reviens sur
finalement ce qui est au coeur de ceux
de ce sondage
ça nous ramène les uns et les autres au
bilan de la politique des macros et à
son est à son image
emmanuel macron président des riches moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est presque une
espèce de tache originelle difficile à
luis paradas on peut dire paradera du
capitaine haddock qui colle à la peau du
président oui c'est une image qui est
quasiment impossible à décoller c'est à
dire que quand vous arrivez à l'elysée
et que vous avez tout de suite cette
image qui est partagée par le plus grand
nombre par la majorité par les médias
bien sûr les premiers véhicules et
ensuite par la population il est très
difficile de la décoller mais ce qu'elle
est injuste cette image il est arrivé il
a pris deux mesures qui reste encore une
fois symbolique et de son quinquennat je
ne dis pas si c'est à tord ou à raison
c'était la suppression de l'sf et moins
5 euros dans les apl pour les étudiants
vous comprenez bien que ces deux mesures
prises en même temps donner un signal
absolument fondamental à son quinquennat
il a beau ensuite proposé à la suite de
la crise des gilet jaune 17 milliards
d'euros coup de pouce au pouvoir d'achat
aucune classe moyenne concernés par ce
coup de pouce n'en a pris en tout cas et
on a pris conscience qu est-ce que
j'aurai mon ressenti et la verrie fille
est en tout cas on parle dans les
sondages dans les enquêtes ou dans les
interviews personne ne parle de 7,17
milliards et emmanuel macron finalement
est resté ce président des riches quoi
qu'il arrive à mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il s'en moque de cette
image ou alors il a essayé quand même
tâche dont je parlais la de l'effacer
alors c'est ce qui est intéressant avec
emmanuel macron c'est que en chine c'est
à dire qu'officiellement et vous dit
qu'il n'en peut plus de cette image et
qu'elle est injuste et que lui il veut
le bien de la nation
simplement quand on regarde un peu dans
les tailles et qu'on laisse traîner une
oreille dans son déplacement dans le lot
en juin dernier vous savez le début de
son tour de france il a dit on m'a dit
président des riches je m'en fous avec
une un argument qui est le même qu'en
2017 on pourrait taxer les gros très
bien mais si on taxe les gros
salaires il se casse donc vous comprenez
bien que c'est exactement la même
logique cinq ans plus tard emmanuel
macron ne veut pas taxer les hauts
revenus or selon une enquête opinionway
paru quasiment au même moment de ce
déplacement dans le lot en juin
72% des français sont favorables à une
taxation des hauts revenus c'est là
qu'il est à la fracture entre emmanuel
macron et les français et le gros des
français parce que qu'est ce que
représente la classe moyenne me suis
aujourd'hui j'aurais de vous dire on
n'arrive pas aujourd'hui à chiffrer mais
quand on me dit la classe populaire les
pauvres les classes moyennes mais à
combien savez c'est un peu tabou en
france à combien on a combien le niveau
de salaire on commence à être classes
moyennes à combien on eric de lagrasse
pauvres a essayé de discussion qui n'en
fin souvenez vous en monsieur hollande
de disait que quelqu'un qui à 6000 euros
de revenus par mois et avec les gammes
riche donc la notion de richesse de
toute façon elle est extrêmement
relative et on s'en sort jamais moi ce
qui me gêne toujours avec ce type de
discours c'est qu'on sent très
rapidement l'instrumentalisation
politique qui est fait derrière parce
que regardons concrètement ce qui se
passe sur le président des riches main
un jeune solutions face et 10 milliards
d'euros qui sont mis pour le recrutement
des jeunes pour faire en sorte de leur
donner du boulot pour faire en sorte de
les aider à rentrer le pont pauvreté 15
milliards un plan qui n'a jamais été
aussi important dans lequel il ya tout
un ensemble qui est fait pour pour les
plus pauvres c'est jamais assez de toute
façon et c'est vrai par rapport à des
gens qu'on a ne compte qu on a dont on
ne s'est jamais occupé parce qu'il ne
votaient pas à l'époque d'ailleurs les
le plan pauvreté on avait dit on ne
travaille pas pour la prochaine élection
contrairement entre guillemets à ce qui
s'est fait avant on travaille pour la
prochaine génération et on pourrait le
reste à charge 2 0 ça n'a jamais été
fait je veux dire aujourd'hui il ya des
gens qui n'allaient pas à chez le
médecin parce qu'ils pouvaient pas se
payer le reste à charge pour le pour
l'audition enfin pour un ensemble de
soins basiques et un rsa genre et je
pourrais multiplier moi qui suis dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire je vois
également tout ce qui a été fait pour
les associations enfin le frêne john
nack c'est injuste bah c'est injuste en
tout cas c'est un prisme c'est un prisme
qui est facilement instrumentalisée
quant à l' isf parlons-en de liesse
générale là dessus c'est des études qui
n'en termine pas l' isf a été présente
pendant 40 ans est-ce que ça résout que
résolu quoi que ce soit en terme social
non donc ce que 70% des français disent
qu'ils sont pour la senza 70 % des
français sont pour ce qui ne les
concerne pas facile
très facile je suis pas sûr qu'un
sondage comme ça et beaucoup de lui mais
quand on regarde mes analyses et
économiste non mais attendez je vais
juste vous opposer cet argument là
puisque le fc e et l'institut montaigne
qui est quand même pas loin des manuels
macro on est plutôt macron compatible
l'institut montaigne ont les mêmes
conclusions c'est à dire que les
conséquences de la politique fiscale
d'emmanuel macron ont bénéficié aux
ménages et si tu allais les plus s
bénéficier même pendant mes jambes et
dans un contexte où les ménages les plus
aisés sont les plus taxés d'europe par
ailleurs donc il ya il ya tout un
contexte qu'il faut avoir en tête et je
terminerai quand même par un paradoxe
statistiques intéressant intéressant et
qui était fakih est facile à
instrumentaliser politiquement savez
vous que quand on augmente le pouvoir
d'achat du plus grand nombre le plus
grand nombre et en les classes moyennes
et constitue aux eaux autour de 2500
euros et plus par mois c'est-à-dire 60%
de la population quand on donc le
salaire des classes moyennes en fait on
dégrade le taux de pauvreté pourquoi
parce que le taux de pauvreté est
calculé sur la base du salaire médian
0,6 fois le salaire médian 60 % et 5
millions ça veut dire que quand vous
augmenter le salaire médian tous ceux
qui étaient à la frange aux alentours de
900 euros tous ceux qui étaient à la
frange qui était aux alentours de 1000
euros qui eux n'en bénéficient pas parce
qu'effectivement malheureusement enfin
la taxe d'habitation elle bénéficia que
ceux qui ont une habitation et ses
terres et ses bas donc il y en a qui y
en a qui se retrouve à être
statistiquement dans les postes qu'ils
ne l'étaient pas avant donc une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat peut
avoir comme conséquence une augmentation
de la pauvreté statistiques tout en
ayant des revenus globaux qui augmente
donc c'est des choses qui sont fins et
des notions qui sont très difficiles à
manipuler et sur lequel malheureusement
il ya une instrumentalisation politique
qui est fin qui est compliqué à contrer
effectivement parce qu'on avait sur
sollicitation par cas parce que quand
quelqu'un qui instrumentalisent donc y
compris
j'adore vous entendre parler d'un ce
qu'est ce que c'est
l'instrumentalisation politique cette
chanson arguments non non je peux pas
vous laisser dire ça sur l'échiquier
politique et à des gens qui n'ont pas
les mêmes visions des choses alors vous
vous arrivez avec vos chiffres vos
statistiques j'ai dit tout à l'heure
pour ce qui concernait l'augmentation la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat ces
scientifiques je ne conteste pas après
tout ce que vous venez de dire les plus
scientifiques on n'est pas dans
l'instrumentalisation on est dans une
vision différente des choses vous dites
que 10 millions d'euros ont été mis sur
le plan pour les jeunes mais le vélo 10
milliards le plan pour les jeunes c'est
que c'est une je viens de jeu sort
demain la conclusion d'une mission sur
le le l'émancipation des jeunes et
l'égalité des chances c'est une une
agglomération je puis dire de toutes les
mesures qui ont été faites jusqu'à
maintenant avec une augmentation
notamment c'est vrai de 2 du nombre de
bénéficiaires de la garantie jeunes qui
va donc entraîner oui il ya eu des
choses de faites personne ne dit que
rien n'a été fait mais par contre que
les plus modestes d'entre nous et ça ça
ce chiffre vous savez autant
effectivement on a du mal à considérer
ce qu'est la classe moyenne monsieur dit
2500 euros pour d'autres c'est plus que
ça mais le seuil de pauvreté il est à
1060 euros je crois par personne et ça
c'est bien et les gens le nombre de
personnes qui sont sur le seuil de
pauvreté il n'a pas baissé
aujourd'hui les charges fixes dont
parlait monsieur tout à l'heure elle
augmente le prix du logement augmentent
terriblement vous parliez des zones
urbaines moi je suis une élue de zones
rurales d'un département attractif je
peux vous garantir que chez moi aussi ça
devient très compliqué pour des gens qui
ont des revenus on va dire classique de
se loger donc tout ça c'est pas de
l'instrumentalisation c'est la réalité
des choses et la réalité de la vie et on
n'empêchera pas les français de
considérer qu emmanuel macron et le
président des riches parce
qu'effectivement dans le même temps il a
supprimé lisf on n'est pas ici pour
débattre du rendu de l'usf mais par
contre d'un point de vue de l de l'image
on ne va pas en discuter ici mais
psychologiquement
il fallait peut-être en même temps de
trouver si je puis dire trouver autre
chose mais c'est la fille parce que dans
les faits il a été transformé en osier
est qui et qui quand même a permis un
certain nombre de français les plus
aisés de voir baisser leurs
contributions à l'impôt et dans le même
temps effectivement on prend une mesure
tout aussi symbolique peut-être qui est
celle d'en lever 5 euros sur les apl oui
c'est symbolique mais ça parle aux
pauvres lisf excusez moi mais c'était un
impôt totalement hypocrite vous parliez
de symbole la
défiscalisation peu de personnes ne
paient certaines fortes qui sont allés
s'installer ailleurs toutes les études
c'est ce qu'on parle d'études et
chiffres l'ont démontré c'est factuel ça
n'a pas servi notre pays ça servait
notre pays on serait les premiers à la
défense ça n'a pas servi notre pays ce
que je conseille à toi si je peux aller
oui et puis je vous laisserai après
deuxième point on a l'impression dans ce
pays on taxe pas les hauts revenus c'est
quand même exceptionnel on a le niveau
de prélèvement vous l'avez rappelé le
plus élevé d'europe voire des pays
industrialisés on ne taxe pas les hauts
revenus mais en fait c'est un drame
cette démagogie vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'on est dans une économie de la
connaissance et on a besoin de gens bien
payés on a besoin d'ingénieurs et ses
ingénieurs par exemple qui coûte cher
moi quand j'embauche quelqu'un 6000
euros ça me coûte douze mille euros
alors très bien il ya des charges la
vraie question à se poser c'est est-ce
que ces prélèvements est ce que la
dépense publique est efficace tout le
monde est ok pour avoir un système de
solidarité là on n'est pas d'accord
c'est lorsque des policiers se plaignent
les hôpitaux sont pas contents
l'éducation nationale se plaint pas
assez de moyens avec le niveau de
prélèvement qu'on a c'est ça qui
interroge comment on rend la dépense
publique plus efficace donc prélevé
toujours plus n'apporte pas de
satisfaction automatique il dit qu'il
faut taxer plus mais on a le niveau
record et ça pas à parler le bonheur à
nos conseils mode répond d'abord j'ai
pas dit qu'il fallait taxer plus mais ce
que je constate quand même c'est que
depuis un certain nombre d'années on
taxe - quand ma main depuis 2010 est oui
sans une amélioration
fin aux taxes - les revenus les plus
élevés alors attendez vous laisser finir
je serai j'oserais juste une parenthèse
et vraiment je vous redonne la parole
monique lubin promis c'est dans le
parisien ce matin on n'a pas pris la
totalité des simulations des bilans qui
avait été fait mais on a choisi quatre
catégories donc ces baisses d'impôt sur
le quinquennat macron un célibataire
sans enfant qui vit dans une grande
ville 16000 euros de revenus annuels 842
euros d'économie couple sans enfant
vingt mille euros x 2 ça fait une
économie de 4650 eurocoupe csp + 3
enfants voilà on est sur des gens qu'il
ya une 90000 euros à eux deux sur
l'année 3500 euros d'économies et les
retraités petite ville dans une maison
trente mille euros de ca fait 3200 euros
d'impôts donc c'est quand même du
pouvoir d'achat en plus ça oui je
réfléchissais bizarrement j'ai pas vu
mais mpb ses portes il
ya des habitations il ya voilà voilà
voilà on va parler notamment de la taxe
d'habitation évidemment si vous mettez
la taxe d'habitation qui prime et oui
bien sûr bon pour en parler aussi on
supprime la taxe d'habitation
rohmérienne en face que vont faire les
collectivités locales qui assurent quand
même une grande partie des services à la
population faites ça c'est des choses
qu'il faudrait aborder dans leur
généralité je voudrais revenir ce ce que
je disais tout à l'heure non seulement
ne taxe pas plus mais j'entends tout de
suite dès qu'on dit on va taxer plus non
il faut pas le faire parce que les hauts
revenus vont partir mais si c'est ce
qu'on entend régulièrement moi ce que je
constate c'est que les pauvres ils
peuvent pas partir et ils peuvent
absolument rien défiscalisées ils
peuvent rien bon voilà donc eux ils
n'ont pas le choix nous on est peut-être
dans un pays où effectivement les taxes
sont importantes je pense qu'il y à des
pays encore un petit peu plus au nord
non il y en a un seul
10% des ménages qui payent 70 % de
l'impôt sur le revenu quand même un
délit les recettes on est on est le pays
le plus risqué alors juste et moi je
suis co alors j'ai halluciné d'avoir ce
débat on est le pays où l'on redistribué
quasiment au monde mais est-ce que
l'impôt sur le revenu aujourd'hui est un
impôt juste
est ce qu'il est mais payé que par un
français sur deux il faudrait peut-être
revoir tout ça également mais si tu
voudrais dire
pardon mais quand on quand on veut
remettre à plat un système fiscal aussi
convivial de la france ça veut dire
qu'on ne fera rien ce qui a été la
politique en gros qui est des fêtes pour
les trente dernières années m'a coûté si
votre avis mais moi c'est
celle là je vais revenir pardon je vais
revenir sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat et me retourner j'espère que
vous avec michaud le directeur général
adjoint d'opinionway est toujours avec
nous en visioconférence frédéric micheau
peut-être revenons au coeur de votre de
votre sondage sur vous avez interrogé
évidemment voilà votre panel
représentatif sur l'impact des manuels
macron sur le pouvoir d'achat et on
parlait des classes moyennes des classes
plus aisées etc qu'est ce qu'il en
ressort
mais aussi les consommations elle est
placée sour confirme ce qui a été dit
par internet quand on interroge les
français sur
les différentes catégories de la
population pour lesquelles les
différentes actions comme les twins qui
ont été conviés par le gouvernement au
cours des cinq dernières années en leur
demandant si ces actions ont un impact
positif négatif ou sur leur pouvoir
d'achat a qu'une seule catégorie pour
laquelle les français jugent et l'action
économique du gouvernement étaient
plutôt positives ce sont les catégories
aisées en revanche ce qui concerne les
catégories populaires et encore plus ces
catégories moyennes
l'action économique du gouvernement sur
le pouvoir d'achat de ces catégories est
jugée négativement en tout cas dans les
perceptions les français 10la les
différentes mesures qui ont été prises a
été négatif sur le pouvoir d'achat de
ces catégories
si on regarde la demande peut-être le
bilan économique des manuels maintenant
dans son intégralité là aussi on parlait
tout à l'heure de paradoxes statistique
est quelque chose qui a été très
intéressant ce bilan d'une manière
générale il est perçu de manière très
négative 58% de la population ou dit que
le bilan emmanuel macron en matière
économique et je rappelle qu'il est des
ministres une économie que l'économie
c'est son domaine d expertise
il lui dit que son bilan dans ce secteur
est négatif c'est beaucoup moins que
françois hollande à la même époque que
de nicolas sarkozy à la même époque mais
ces semaines ci français sur deux qui me
disent que ce bilan globalement négatif
mais quand on regarde on mesure par
mesure quand nous testions mesure par
mesure et que nous demandons en français
si chacune de ces mesures est une bonne
ou une mauvaise chose la plupart de ces
mesures sont bien jugée sévère par
exemple évidemment pour les ailes des
entreprises pendant la période du que 8
87% des français existe c'est une bonne
chose oui et c'est unanime un mail
faussement la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation 80 tandis que c'est une
bonne chose le prélèvement à la source
de l'impôt dû c'est une bonne chose pour
80% des français même et c'est une
mesure qui est très clivante la réforme
de l'assurance chômage 58 ans sans les
français nous disent que c'est une bonne
chose y avait une seule mesure qui est
jugé comme une mauvaise chose à 68 ans
en défense elles la suppression de la
route sur lafarge bon merci pour ce pour
ces détails c'était effectivement
passionnant moi ce que je retiens quand
même c'est effectivement ce chiffre sur
les les mesures des death et j'ai un peu
le sentiment que c'est comme si on avait
oubliez globalement ce que ce
gouvernement a fait pour le secteur
économique en général alors je vais
donner la parole tient pour quelques
secondes au ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire parce qu'il faut là il faut
bien que les membres du gouvernement eux
mêmes rappelle cette action écoutez le
depuis 2010 est ça a été le fil rouge de
notre politique économique nous avons
fait en sorte que les salaires les plus
modestes touche davantage à la fin du
bois pour que le travail paye c'est la
prime d'activité celle défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires c'est les
suppressions de charges sociales au
total ces 170 euros de plus par mois au
niveau du smic que l'état a rajouté
sabri ce sachet j'ai entendu beaucoup de
deux personnes dire attention va y avoir
une vague de faillites moi même ça m'est
arrivé de l'employé l'image une espèce
de vague qui était gelé et qui est
qu'ils allaient se déverser sur le pays
quand les mesures des dalles est allé
s'interrompre elle n'a pas eu lieu cette
vague de faillites prix nous effondrons
n'a jamais parlé président geoffroy roux
de bézieux a jamais dit qu'ils auraient
une vague de faillites il avait
d'ailleurs dit quand on parlait d'un
million de chômeurs en plus que c'était
pas du tout les retours qu'on avait du
terrain puisque nous ont fait pas de
l'économie powerpoint on aller retour de
tous les départements de france des
entreprises en direct et le gouvernement
a agi très rapidement et tout ça ça a eu
un impact évident sur le pouvoir d'achat
des français sur le pouvoir d'achat en
tout cas on a protégé les salariés
puisque l'activité partielle ça a permis
de protéger le pouvoir d'achat bien
évidemment on n'a pas augmenté les
salaires pendant cette période mais on à
protéger l'existant à protéger l'outil
industriel ça a permis de redémarrer
très vite la l'économie à redémarrer
extrêmement rapidement et donc il ya eu
ces actions qui ont permis de geler ou
de mettre sous cloche l'économie
maintenant c'est les négociations
salariales qui se passe tous les ans il
ya eu aussi des primes je le rappelle
puisqu'il ya eu plusieurs fois des
primes défiscaliser donc ça a permis
aussi de soutenir vous parliez des
travailleurs dits de la première ligne a
eu des choses qui ont été faites dans la
grande distribution il ya certains
groupes qui ont distribué des primes qui
ont donné des primes lorsqu'il le
pouvait mais d'une façon plus structurée
les négociations elles ont lieu chaque
année dans les entreprises et là il ya
des augmentations de salaires surtout
dans les secteurs où il ya des pénuries
de main d'oeuvre vous savez les
chauffeurs routiers il ya des
augmentations de 5 à 8% par an d
inflation qui pose vraiment problème
pour des entreprises qui ont des marges
très faibles mais si on veut augmenter
les salaires il faut aussi avoir une
logique globale est ce que dans les
appels d'offres publics ou privés
lorsque je suis pas ici au sénat vous
recrutez une société de gardiennage ou
de nettoyage vous choisissez cette
société par rapport notamment aux prix
sur la note que vous attribuez pour
sélectionner une société je pense qu'il
ya 80% de la note qui est lié aux prix
donc si vous voulez qu'on augmente les
serres il faut aussi avoir une logique
globale et donc il y aura un impact sur
les le prix des produits quand
mcdonald's a augmenté le salaire minimum
des salariés le prix du du burger il a
augmenté un mois après alors je voudrais
maintenant qu'on fasse un faux cul je
vous en avais parlé tout à l'heure sur
la situation des des jeunes et sur ce
que emmanuel macron essaye de modifier
pour la précarité et la situation
économique des jeunes c'est samia de
cire qui va nous rejoindre tout de suite
sur le plateau de sens public bonjour
samia bienvenus il ya ce revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes à quoi ça
va ressembler mais bon sort thomas en
fait on n'a pas encore vraiment tous les
détaillants puisqu'ils ne seront
dévoilés qu'en octobre mais on connaît
déjà les grandes lignes de ce dispositif
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il s'agit d'un
revenu de 500 euros par mois pour des
jeunes de 16 à 25 ans qui sont sans
formation sans emploi ou qui occupent un
emploi précaire c'est un revenu qui leur
serait versé pendant 18 mois pas plus et
surtout à une condition chaque jeune
doit s'engager à suivre un
accompagnement renforcé et s'il ne
remplit pas ce contrat si n'est pas
assis lui et bien ces versements pour
être suspendu alors faut toujours se
méfier les effets d'annoncé parce qu'il
ya parfois des dispositifs qui existait
déjà revenu en échange d'un cône un
accompagnement renforcé la garantie
jeunes c'est un peu la même chose et
raison thomas si on se base sur ce que
l'on sait pour l'instant du futur revenu
d'engagement c'est sensiblement la même
chose que la garantie jeunes a garanti
jeunes qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
dispositif qui avait été créée ou tout
du moins pérenniser sous françois
hollande en 2017 alors qu'est ce que
c'était et bien qu est-ce que c'est
plutôt c'est une aide l'an cordes de 500
euros par mois pour des 16 25 ans en
échange d'un parcours d'accompagnement
tout y est pour l'instant sur le papier
il n'y aucune différence sauf peut-être
quand on s'intéresse au public concerné
puisque le gouvernement a laissé
entendre qu'il pourrait y avoir un
million de personnes concernées par ce
futur revenu d'engagement contre 200
mille personnes aujourd'hui visé chaque
année par la garantie jana une petite
question de budget même si on est autant
de l'argent magique ça coûterait combien
elle va pour l'instant ne s'est pas le
gouvernement n'a annoncé aucun chiffre
et c'est bien là que se concentrent du
coup toutes les critiques parce
qu'aujourd'hui les missions locales qui
assurent l'accompagnement des jeunes qui
sont suivis par le dispositif garanti
jeune elle dispose que d'un seul
conseiller pour 50 jeunes maximum dont
vous l'aurez compris on est sur des
ressources humaines déjà très tendu et
écouter ce qu'on pense patrick kanner
qui est le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat c'est un fait viable
parce que les milliers d'accompagnement
nécessaires ne sont pas là il faut même
déjà les former et donc on est en fin de
quinquennat dans une démarche purement
électoralistes voilà donc les
socialistes ce qui se propose c'est
plutôt d'étendre le rsa dès l'âge de 18
ans parce qu'aujourd'hui si vous n'avez
pas 25 ans avec vous n'avez jamais
travaillé vous n'avez le droit à aucun
revenu de solidarité mais le
gouvernement et la droite sont opposés à
cette 1ère à sa jeune merci beaucoup
merci ça mais on retrouve tout à l'heure
dans notre second débat notre débat plus
prospectif plus décalé qui sera
consacrée au thème de la décroissance
est-ce que c'est un modèle salvateur ou
dangereux
ce sera ça promet d'être passionnant il
nous reste quelques minutes pour pour
conclure ce débat sur le pouvoir d'achat
tient joue je donne on a alors c'est
très subjectif on a été picorer dans
l'est dans les programmes des candidats
à un certain nombre de propositions et
je vous propose les propositions des
candidats qui sont à gauche fabien
roussel un smic mensuel à 1800 euros de
brut jean luc mélenchon blocage des prix
de produits de première nécessité arnaud
montebourg augmentation du smic d'au
moins 10% à hidalgo augmentation de 15 %
des personnels invisible on revient aux
premières lignes dont on parlait
sandrine rousseau pop écologie les verts
revenu d'existence de 850 euros à partir
de 18 ans encore une fois c'est
subjectif il ya plein d'autres
propositions d'autres candidats on a
fait nos choix est ce que c'est un
marqueur fort de la campagne qui s'ouvre
uniquement cette question le salaire
cette session une augmentation des sûr
je pense que ce sera un marqueur fort
bien évidemment parce que toutes ces
personnes qu'on a mis en avant une fois
de plus
au début de la crise
il faut on en a absolument besoin je
vais parler de la dépendance on devait
voir arriver une loi dépendance qui ne
va pas arriver bon on sait que la
population vieillit aujourd'hui le
modèle qui est choisie c'est le fait de
rester à domicile on ne crée plus de
places en ehpad pour que les gens
restent à domicile il faut créer des
emplois et pour créer des emplois il
faut trouver du personnel ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que ce
sont des métiers difficiles qui ne sont
pas rémunérés à la hauteur de à laquelle
il devrait être rémunéré donc ces gens
là attendent beaucoup de nous mais les
français en règle générale qui
s'inquiètent à partir d'un certain
moment pour leurs vieux jours et la
façon dont ils vont vieillir chez eux
s'inquiètent aussi donc oui ça sera et
puis tous ces salariés qui sont
aujourd'hui au smic ou à peine un peu au
dessus du smic et qui voit rarement
quand même leur pouvoir d'achat
augmenter parce que dès qu'ils ont une
toute petite augmentation et quand on
est salarié dans le privé dans une
petite pme on comprend bien que
l'employeur ne puisse pas donner d
augmentation chaque année très
importante
dès qu'ils ont une petite augmentation
de salaire le prix du loyer augmente le
prix des crédits enfin générer des
crédits augmente le prix des matières
alors augmente et donc le pouvoir
d'achat lui ils demandent finalement c
est ce qu on est dans une période et ce
paradoxe que personne ne peut comprendre
d'eux d'entreprises qui veulent
embaucher et qui n'arrivent pas à
trouver du personnel et d'un taux de
chômage qui reste très élevé est-ce que
c'est lié uniquement à la question des
salaires est ce que les métiers en
tension sont en tension parce que les
personnels sont fins et bien payé ça
serait trop simple si c'était un
problème de salaires on augmente les
salaires on trouvera les personnes en
fait il ya un problème de formation on a
une inadéquation entre les personnes qui
arrivent sur le marché du travail et les
besoins des entreprises c'est pas
nouveau c'est pas lié aux copies de sa
date maintenant de d'année c'est un
problème structurel et donc la question
c'est comment on fait des reconversions
professionnelles rapide comment on
génère des formations qui répondent aux
besoins du marché du travail comme en
insert sur le marché du travail et
comment on a plus de mobilité
géographique parce que c'est ça aussi le
problème des emplois à bourges un messi
des cas concrets mais j'allais visiter
une boîte à bourges c'était il ya un
mois 50 s'est dit ouvert qui trouve pas
preneur des couturiers des couturières
dans l'avion c'est à dire que les
salaires n'y sont pour rien
les salaires c'était des salaires entre
2000 et 3000 euros je sais pas je suis
pas un spécialiste de ce secteur ça me
semble pas bah je sais pas mais à
bourges c'est pas une ville très cher où
les loyers sont très très cher des
salaires entre 2000 et 3000 au pour des
couturières non mais il ya un hic elle
je savais pas qui est ce enfin ça
parce que ce que je veux dire par là
c'est quand même ça c'est pas qu'une
question de salaire oui ils trouvent pas
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'essence des
formations de pôle emploi vous avez des
six formations d'apprentissage mais ça
change quand même un peu
c'est un débat sans fin parce que
finalement cette revendication
d'augmentation salariale a toujours
existé il est d'ailleurs assez légitime
mais elle mais elle ne s'arrête jamais
en fait parce que c'est pas là qu'est le
sujet le sujet il est sûr effectivement
la formation on le voit dans le dans
leurs oeufs dans le revenu d'engagement
jeu tel qu'il est présenté là ce qui est
important c'est ce que dit monsieur
kader c'est comment on va trouver des
gens pour accompagner ces jeunes là mais
si on ne se remet pas dans cette optique
là on ne sortira jamais de la spirale si
on ne réforme pas complètement
l'information professionnelle la
formation tout au long de la vie si on
ne met pas en regard les demandes
d'emploi avec les offres d'emploi on ne
sortira jamais les pauvres de leurs
conditions sont les former sur l'or de
la possibilité par un accompagnement de
pouvoir monter sur marché du travail le
salaire derrière savez c c'est quand
même accessoire par rapport à la
problématique de pouvoir être utile de
pouvoir se sentir digne d'avoir un
travail mais qui revient alors il ya
d'autres leviers via pas seulement le
salaire le la participation
l'intéressement c'est pour sa
répartition est pour ça que
l'augmentation des salaires en plus
c'est un piège c'est un piège monstrueux
parce que augmenté salaires veut dire
contribuer à augmenter l'inflation veut
dire réaction de la banque centrale qui
un jour ou l'autre augmentera les taux
d'intérêt ne veut dire une dette
insoutenable alors qu'aujourd'hui elle
est soutenable parce que nous n'avons
pas de taux d'intérêt d'accord donc on
est dans un piège qui fait que
finalement santé salaire n'est pas
forcément la bonne solution en revanche
mettre en place des mécanismes de
répartition de la valeur créée non pas
par anticipation donc on injecte pas de
l'argent neuf qui va augmenter
l'inflation mais nous on prend la valeur
qu'ils créent et on l'a on la répartie
moi c'est ce que je fais dans mon
entreprise enfin je viens là on est en a
la capacité d'accompagner les salaires
des salariés par rapport à la santé
économique de l'entreprise et non pas le
faire avant le faire après mais vraiment
faire du de l'actionnariat salarié faire
de l'intéressement participation mettre
en place un ensemble de mécanismes qui
accompagne la création de la valeur le
débat est terminé merci beaucoup à tous
je pense que oui bah ça c'est bon signe
ça quand on est frustré ça veut dire que
c'était passionnant et qui avait encore
beaucoup de choses à raconter merci
beaucoup à tous d'y avoir participé